[Music]
in better solutions newest I thought you
were gonna say something each I thought
I didn't know you're finished I'm plenty
of playing solutions interesting okay
okay submitted by a hot cold brew oh
yeah it take cold brew then boil it
maybe if cold brew made differently yes
it is yes it's brewed cold you uh it's
steeped yeah it's deep for like 24 hours
completely different so it's less it's
less accurate it's not as bitter so
that's why people like cold brew
compared to regular coffee smoother Bill
Gates brought a Charles human poop
onstage during a speech about
reinventing the toilet [ __ ] I wonder if
it's his own [ __ ] it is his own [ __ ] oh
it's a billion dollar coupe poopoo this
was like on my outdo Steve Jobs I don't
give a [ __ ] we do read about it it was
for the toilets like so that it's for
sanitation like there's he's pushing
from better sanitation around the world
yeah that's that was his point so his
point donating poop in jars now no I
mean I don't remember I don't I don't
remember reading why yeah you bought his
poop on stage but that's donating to
that okay this is gonna sound really
stupid are we talking about like better
toilets like teksu eyes are like better
sanitation like better toilets for
everyone probably like better like
plumbing and everything like okay
everyone's right cuz it's um it's he's
talking about how there is five hundred
and twenty five thousand children under
the age of five that die every year
because of bad sanitation and it
contributes to malnutrition and spread
of disease I bet you most of that is
like India or something poor countries
that they don't really have like an
entire you know sanitation or sewer
system and so he's been investing a lot
into trying to create like a better
toilet or a better sanitation system
where these kids don't have to die
because of this or have malnutrition and
stuff and so that's when he went onstage
and he referred to as a little exhibit
and he like showed his glass oh I don't
understand why
huh that looks like peanut butter yo he
needs to get his [ __ ] check yeah I feel
like he needs to address other health
concerns before sick that's like some
nasty poop how come there's no wrinkles
in his boot Dookie it's cuz it was like
process and [ __ ] like in [ __ ] it's just
nasty
wait well because he's talking about the
new sanitation and so it was to make a
point because around the world there
aren't proper sanitation or sewerage
sewage systems and I know sewage type
and so um there's just a lot of
unsanitary human waste sitting around
the world there's kids that go out and
play and their be exposed to this all
the time and they're also there's also a
link between like bad sanitation disease
death and malnutrition like I mentioned
and so he's just trying to fix this
problem in the world and so I'm gonna
show you a video of one of the toilets
that people have invented using the
funds that he's given when I was a kid I
used to hate it when poop used to trick
me what you guys are been tricked by
peekaboo and then goes back it no like
you're playing in like a sand like a
playground oh yeah and until you always
like it like if you dig at the bottom
it's like it gets muddy alright so you
can make little sand balls and then
sometimes I'll see like a round being
covered in sand on my Oh pre-made sand
bar perfect I grabbed it and I squeezed
it it was just [ __ ] do key card in
sand on my [ __ ] I like do my cat [ __ ]
human [ __ ] whatever it had never ever
done that in my life really you don't
make mud balls no I've never ever ever
you guys never went and grabbed like
played in the sandbox and then they like
[ __ ] cat [ __ ] or something came out
yeah you're like oh there's a premade
one right here [ __ ] I got no [ __ ]
probably did not play sandbox yeah like
at the park or at the school or whatever
I would find quarters and like toys I
find cool thank you
did you guys ever try to make super soft
sand yeah how do you do it what is it
what your method uh so you dig all the
way to the bottom where there it's like
clay like wet um
mud and then you just put water in your
mouth from the water fountain then you
bring in and you spit it so that it's
super muddy
well that's interesting you guys are
[ __ ] nasty
human beings man you and I would do what
I would get a [ __ ] bottle of water
all right when you're a little ass kid
dirt I mean and we grew up before
bottled water was a thing because
remember Whitten are like bottled water
was not a thing oh that's right that's
true yeah it's a new thing that I
remember talking [ __ ] about bottled
water bottles waste look you'll have
gallons and that family size people
would deliver water and then they put
the water again like it in you it like
this convenience to go like personal
size thing it's a new thing we didn't
have cut like we didn't have any of that
maybe it's because the playground that I
planet was in my grandma's apartment
so I just go to apartment and get well
no it wasn't like that for us no the
sandbox was a very dramatic place for me
traumatic I what happened to you man
that shouldn't your show should be
called what happened to me because you
have always tried to stories about
everything they don't really have much
luck in life you know I should be best
friend because I was chubby they
nicknamed me punky yes pumpkin that's a
whole different story so cute it's not
cute like I'm the carriage they're all
princesses
you know what that used to call me in
elementary school spagett yeah I rather
be called in any day
and then they used to like do these like
physical activities during recess and
then every time I tried to join them I
couldn't keep up because I was pumpkiny
and so then they would make fun of me so
that I would do this routine I'd sit in
the sandbox and then they'd be like oh
come on Stephanie let's go and I felt
like they were doing it like maliciously
like let's go make fun of you so that I
would say this is quick said and my foot
is stuck so I can't leave okay in the
sand but it was like regular sand and
everybody knew that but like I was like
it's quicksand guys and they're like god
this kid this pumpkins weird yeah I
don't know your sad stories don't make
me sad they make me happy
your sad stories makes me not want to be
friends with you the teacher calls your
name like I would sit there and
dramatically no one's even [ __ ] look
out like grabbed my leg and do this [ __ ]
to me like you know way up the line and
you're like dude I just picture your
agent like god this kid is so [ __ ]
dramatic man god damn it somebody take
this [ __ ] kid away
that's dope great I never felt like [ __ ]
and Marik's is like a school samba I
found it I found [ __ ] oh maybe we did
find it but we knew what it was so we
weren't we didn't touch it oh we were
just like I think that's [ __ ] I'm gonna
go play over here I think that's a we
did no but one time I saw like okay so
like sometimes you find these Dookie
covered sad things right and then I eat
like one time I'll grab it
it's like smeared all over my [ __ ] their
[ __ ] so another time I'll see it and
then I'll be like [ __ ] he's gonna try to
trick me and I'll grab it and I like
smell it oh [ __ ] thank God it's [ __ ]
trees I throw it away but there's one
other time I don't know how this
happened I grabbed it and I smelled it
and it was the best-smelling thing ever
it was like a kumquat lemon thing so
some house it got wet and it got covered
in sand so not all the times when you
see so you can't you can't judge all of
them so as a child your journey in life
was to once again fine that said and so
you just kept crab is this it No
Oh poop again oh you can't stop trying
because what if the next one is like a
judge all the sad things the same some
of them are Dookie some of our dirt some
of them is a kumquat in the covered in
sand but the probability is really low
all that has sand around it isn't [ __ ]
yeah that's what I'm saying you can't
judge them all you say that you wouldn't
want a beer fridge you guys would've
been best friends dude know what you're
talking about
I'm not judging that I would've been
there playing and I would looked at her
like what the [ __ ] this ain't quick
sandy crazy
like [ __ ] [ __ ] digging and looking
for [ __ ] oh that's Dookie he's like I
just remember watching kids on the
[ __ ] monkey bars and swinging it [ __ ]
but then I was so fat to be too tiring
so I just got one alright we're done
we're done with this game this game is
stupid I know kids these things have
that slider thing oh I got all new toys
anyway we're talking about toilets here
so the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
started the reinvent the toilet
challenge back in 2011 it funded two
hundred million dollars in grants for
universities around the world to develop
the next generation toilet and so they
were trying they're trying to develop a
waste processing system that doesn't
need to be hooked up to a typical
sanitation and sewer grid and so oh here
we go
this is a one of them this from the UK
there's a self processing toilet Charlie
Brown music Peanuts characters I like
that like that that's dull yeah and so
all this [ __ ] goes down and then it gets
rounded up and incinerated well you
can't put toilet paper in there can you
like ash that's you can't even water
right it falls into water I think it
does that's just more tourist for you as
a kid hey did you [ __ ] empty out the
Dookie canister fine if it didn't Center
rates it there's gonna be [ __ ] smoke
though oh yeah gonna be smoky somewhere
yeah and then it filters up the water so
then you drink it no not that's a drink
it's not clean enough to drink
but you can like water plants or
reflesherator salut
that's great that's insane there's like
one of them damn so many smart people in
this world
yeah I'm not contributing to that all
good I just feel so shitty because we
just had this conversation about having
a quick fan and then people are changing
we're contributing to people's long our
lives because we make them laugh and
smile or they make them sell where the
Eco booster they make themselves feel
smarter because we're so I feel so weird
with some of these kids that we go to
compile a these college shows right
it'll be like an Ivy League college and
I look up to you I'm like what are you
doing bro don't watch the [ __ ]
Princeton dude you have a future that
I've learned so much stuff from you they
learned what not to do with you that's
actually very helpful oh yeah that's
right I can't be like this bucket idiot
yeah I thought he was skinny for 30
years stupid
[Music]